[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we interviewed Rachel a couple weeks ago
sorry about that I think my mic was off
welcome welcome welcome to the show it
is Wednesday noon Eastern 11 Central
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
we have MJ MJ says welcome to the [ __ ]
list Roundup hashtag [ __ ] Army welcome
welcome everybody here
um we have we have a special guest for
you today um we wanted to bring her back
because we wanted to talk to Rachel
bidikoffer about strategic outrage and
how the Democrats can win the 2022
midterms and what that looks like what
is that strategic outrage how do you
point that in the right direction how do
you how do you put that Arrow
in the bow and aim it at the Target so
we got to do that today and we also are
going to go through the shitless Roundup
later on in the day we might have Gabe
joining us all you Gabe fans out there
I'm not sure if he's going to be joining
us today but it is possible he might
join us for the [ __ ] list Roundup maybe
we'll round up the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends with Gabe there's there's
some things trending um people are
comparing Willie Nelson to Kid Rock I
don't know what kind of [ __ ]
comparison that is I mean does anyone
even remember what the [ __ ] if a Kid
Rock song is
does anyone anyone know even the title
of a Kid Rock song I don't know I don't
know maybe maybe there's one or two in
there you know the one hit wonder over
there
um I guess he's got a new song called uh
let's go Brandon this is really [ __ ]
stupid this is really [ __ ] stupid
they just can't quit with this stupid
ass [ __ ]
um you know they they rail on Joe Biden
for leaning into the mic and calling
douchey a stupid son of a [ __ ] the
other day and here is Kid Rock they're
all cheering him oh he's got a song [ __ ]
Joe Biden I mean it just
there are parodies of in and of
themselves I mean we have Tucker Carlson
talking about how how M M's are
transitioning from high heels to to
tennis shoes what the [ __ ] I had to do I
had to do 20 minutes yesterday on this
[ __ ] how Tucker Carlson gets boners over
Eminem's why in the hell do we have to
talk about this [ __ ] in this country we
got real [ __ ] to take care of like
voting rights and stuff new people got
us distracted we gotta we got a war
gonna happen uh in Ukraine the entire
Republican party is on Putin's side of
course they are of course they are why
wouldn't they want want to be on the
autocrat side that that makes perfect
[ __ ] sense
in this timeline how the [ __ ] did we get
here
well we'll find out maybe Rachel will
give us some insight here when we bring
her in but I want to make a few
announcements again you guys know that
we're on every single weekday now two
hours every single weekday noon Eastern
11 Central we're going to beat the hell
out of this microphone we're gonna yell
and scream we're gonna cuss [ __ ] them
because we need to go after this thing
2022 is important but but the news is is
that we don't have a Wednesday afternoon
show now now that the podcast is on
every single weekday we move the time
permanently to noon Eastern 11 Central
so it'll be it'll be right here every
single weekday so go to the YouTube
channel whatever it is that the hell I'm
supposed to say about subscribing to the
YouTube channel you know click this
click that uh hit subscribe hit the Bell
note of whatever I'm supposed to say to
make sure that you see the show go do
that whatever that is go do that and
we'll be good whatever the YouTubers say
I don't know I don't know what it is and
if you're on Twitch go follow us on
Twitch don't uh don't discount twitch I
think it's good people say it's glitchy
but you know what what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do it's a bunch of
Gamers over there but you know we can
work through this also follow us on
Twitter I don't know if you guys went
and voted for the bonehead of the week
poll we got the bonehead of the week
pull up
uh on at Tony Michael's pod so go files
over there also follow at the Tony
Michaels and at I am Gabe Sanchez uh
follow us over there you have to because
you got to participate in the bonehead
of the week pole and the reason why is
because every Friday in the second hour
of the show we're gonna do the bonehead
of the week we're gonna break down who
the bonehead of the week is and
apparently it looks like this week's
poll Don Donald Trump Jr is winning
which if you put him on a bonehead of
the week pull I mean God that's that's
some stiff ass competition isn't it I
mean I'm just saying the booger sugar
videos that he puts out come on this is
this is not this is not hard uh Yoda
says morning morning [ __ ] and fuckets
good morning Yoda nice to see you here
nice to see everyone here all right
let's let's go to a quick break and when
we come back we'll have Rachel don't
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere stay
right there
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
thanks for hanging out
uh MJ likes the uh Babel commercial
Everyone likes the Babel commercial
these Alpha cups out there these Alpha
cup just can't handle it
[Music]
thanks for joining us we have Rachel
bitkov or Rachel hey thanks for joining
us today how are you I'm good man what a
what an entertaining show you put on oh
well you know what appreciates that yeah
well I I I I try I try to make them
laugh I try to fire him up you know yeah
we got to do some stuff over here we get
we ain't got time to waste which is
which is why I wanted to bring you on
we've been trying to work this to where
you come on
um for the last couple weeks maybe you
should come on like every week and give
us an update of what's going on out
there because you're you're watching
these polls you're watching some of
these things that are happening inside
um these races and stuff and I've been
talking about strategic outrage here on
the show we kind of I don't know I guess
I guess you coined the phrase on the
interview that we had a couple weeks ago
which if people want to go watch that
interview it is on YouTube uh you should
go check it out because uh not not only
did we play trivia but um we you kind of
break down especially in the second half
after the trivia this strategic outrage
so tell us where are we at on this
strategic outrage where where are we
headed here for 2022 what do we need to
accomplish with this with this strategic
outrage yeah so you know just to recap
with everyone right we're talking about
how we're going to go head to head with
with a party that's declared open War I
mean it's a it's a war that's been
declared on us we have no choice but to
fight it we can choose not to fight it
and do the appeasement route that change
it worked out great for the UK right so
we're not going to do that we are going
uh balls to the wall and we're getting
people into this concept of hey maybe
maybe we should try some of these
techniques that Republicans use because
believe it or not we're all competing in
in the in the conversion pool for swing
voters so if fear outrage disappoint you
know an emotion is working over there
I'm pretty sure we can get people uh
motivated using similar uh techniques
getting people to think about a few
things and get really pissed off about
them that is strategic outrage in a
nutshell right Mountain making mountains
out of mole Hills about something like
CRT right you know they they turn this I
mean we had people dying all over the
state of Virginia
who were listening to Republicans right
oh don't worry about it's just the flu
don't get a vaccine you're a [ __ ] if
you do right right right and like yeah
we let that [ __ ] campaign close out
on race in schools Jesus you know so
strategic outrage is about directing our
angst to the proper channel the
Republican party and then putting all of
this angst to use to maybe save
democracy because one of the things that
we're facing in this midterm is a a
purposely strategically deflated
Democratic base it was strategically
deflated by the gop's obstruction
strategy the purpose of that strategy
was to keep Joe Biden from giving you
the [ __ ] that you want so that you would
stay home in 22 and they can take over
the government uh so uh you know don't
let them win [ __ ] twice right not
only do you not have of your child care
but you also you know are going to hand
Congress back to a Republican party
that's engaged in in a massive you know
dismantle the rule of law I think right
[ __ ] them well you know right well you
know I've been talking about this a lot
on the show and even in Twitter spaces
is that we have to stay pissed we have
to go [ __ ] vote and when I say go
[ __ ] you know because everyone says stay
pissed well it's not just enough to stay
pissed you have to go [ __ ] vote but
when I say that I mean go get engaged I
don't just mean Mark a ballot um go
[ __ ] vote means that it's contacting
your your your county party Google it
Google the county that you're in go
engage with them engage engage however
you can with the candidates wherever you
can go to get engaged but more
importantly more importantly Democrats
have to stop being scared of politics
and government I've been saying this for
a long time a long time that politics
and government are two separate things
Republicans have understood this for
decades like they know that government
is one thing politics and the noise is a
completely separate thing and the
politics enables you to be the
government like without politics you
can't be government and you cannot
govern you can't do the things to
legislate and administrate policies that
you want to have Joe Biden can yell and
scream all day long right but if he
doesn't have a senate or a house that
will pass anything absolutely anything
well he's completely [ __ ] what is he
going to do I mean he has he has the
power of executive orders but that's not
just not enough for what people want
that's kind of like the cancel student
debt argument but we can't get in the
weeds with every single one of these
line items on the bill we have to stay
focused and this is what they've always
done is stay focused on the the task at
hand to get to get to where we can
govern once we can govern we can do all
those line item things and Democrats can
find out the details rather minimum
wages x amount of dollars rather uh you
start school at three you start school
at four
rather uh what kind of college debt is
eliminated you know we can have all
those conversations but we cannot have
them if you have I don't know like Steve
Bannon the speaker of the house like
you're not gonna have those [ __ ]
conversations if I should just take over
this country right yeah and what really
pisses me off Tony I mean you know in
insofar as like there are external and
and internal like things right and the
external [ __ ] is one thing right but
internally I mean you if you're the
Biden team like there's no political
benefit to you to pretend that you're
governing in normal circumstances okay
and that's where they were they totally
[ __ ] up they should have come out of
the out of the inaugural and said look
this is I mean I know what we talked
about on the stomp but this I mean look
what almost just happened we almost just
lost American democracy we don't have an
honest opposition you cannot craft
[ __ ] public policy in the United
States of America with one party unless
you seize power and consolidate it and
turn it into an autocracy because our
system is designed in such a way to buy
purposely by Fury gate policy into at
least two factions two parties and you
know it's not a parliamentary system so
you don't get the coalitional stuff
going we we've got you know we've got
institutional constraints here guys and
if we want policy we got to make it
really [ __ ] clear the reason you have
you you see an earth that's on fire
isn't because of the goddamn Democrats
okay it's not Joe manchin it's [ __ ]
the Republican party they killed the
Earth then when they got busted and it
was clear that they that climate change
was occurring they made a hoax about it
they paid tobacco lobbyists to create an
entire [ __ ] host about climate change
right and now they're obstructing
climate legislation don't I mean
Manchester well to own the limbs right
to own the lips this is on that right
this is this is crazy because almost
everything that we're seeing even even
down to just this week with Ukraine and
Russia I mean they're absolutely 100 all
in with Putin which is [ __ ] just
flabbergasting that one of our our our
[ __ ] major parties in this country
tree is putting their weight behind
Putin be to own the libs or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] are you people
talking about do you want America in
general like I know we you want to fight
about guns and abortion and [ __ ] but
like his goal his goal is to tear down
democracy and I think that's the
realization that we need to come to is
that there's a certain percentage of the
population in this country that have
been absolutely convinced that democracy
doesn't work and that's why they want
autocracy that's why they've seen the
golden calf and Trump and I mean they've
kind of abandoned him a little bit but
not the idea of him right like there's
so many of these [ __ ] waiting in the
wing to be the next Trump uh DeSantis
and some of these others really he's
he's probably up there right now as the
top until he probably [ __ ] up and steps
on Trump's Toes or who knows what oh no
they're gonna battle it out dude I mean
that's some good [ __ ] right there right
if you really want to get into like some
good like uh you know War strategory the
the fight in Florida right now guys I
mean that is good [ __ ] because you've
got to have some massive paranoia coming
in like as de Santa's actively working
against Trump for that nomination is
Trump working against DeSantis they
don't trust each other they're both
skeezy [ __ ] so they're no doubt
undercutting each other the whisper
campaign within the country club set
must be fantastic in that regard and uh
you know it's probably the only thing we
have going for us is that we've got two
uh you know uh aspiring autocrats who
want to compete for that party mantle
right now and that at least keeps them a
little distracted on the infighting
well right and and I think I think we
could use that as a strategic outrage is
to keep them [ __ ] killing each other
because they do that so well with us
right they're like oh well are you gonna
have minimum wage at 15 or 18 an hour
Democrats fight for like four four
[ __ ] months over three dollars while
they destroy every [ __ ] uh legislator
and every piece of government that they
possibly can and we're like oh what we
turn around what what happened we were
arguing about minimum wage and they took
away all this other [ __ ] they took away
women's Liberty in Mississippi and Texas
and like Jesus Christ if if we can
actually put wedges in between these
[ __ ]
um that's part of the Strategic outrage
too so it's not just about getting
Democrats elected it's about letting the
[ __ ] sandwich eat the [ __ ] sandwich
right yep yep oh yeah the more that
we're talking every day we gotta be
talking about them dude and I get hit
with this [ __ ] all the time because of
the data science component of my my uh
you know my uh resume so like oh well
you know look at this you've got you
know the culture War stuff is pushing
people away yeah okay well number one
there's like five [ __ ] Democrats that
want to defund the police in total like
I mean ranking fine
so it's a made-up it's still a made-up
controversy right and right you cannot
control the other [ __ ] side so you
can tell I mean it's not like Jamie
Harrison in South Carolina or um Doug
Jones and Alabama Iran like they held
those positions right right What
mattered was the illusion the GOP
created here we've got the best goddamn
clay you could ever [ __ ] hope to work
with because these people are
certifiably nuts they're stupid as [ __ ]
and and even worse they're all criminals
right you're right right they're all
having to go into the January 6th select
committee and and and and plea the fifth
so they don't self-incriminate
themselves on federal sedition charges
and be tied in with these [ __ ] proud
boys it's ridiculous oh my God yes and
we've got the whole like Democratic
campaign like world is like handling oh
my what do we do about the narrative
with the pandemic oh my what do we do
about like the five crazy [ __ ] people
in the Democratic party I'm like new
baby you should point out
right right maybe we should point out
that like they're [ __ ] crazy people
are in charge of the party and this is
what they want to do to you right right
right like this is what they want to do
to you not to some nameless faceless
brown-skinned person that they don't
give a [ __ ] about or you know whatever
right this is what you is gonna happen
to you under this GOP autocracy because
if you're trying to persuade these you
know these myopic white swing
suburbanites that got afraid of their
kids learning about Tony Morrison in
school you gotta [ __ ] hit them where
they are you can't hit them where you
want them to be I want them to be
persuadable by you know hey we should
not steal the right to vote from um
people of color but unfortunately that's
not how these people think and that's
how anyone really thinks I mean not to
harp on white white people human
psychology almost 90 of us is
self-interested right right
deal with that self-interest moment and
there's absolutely not one thing in the
autocratic GOP plan that doesn't impact
every family working class middle class
you know giant middle class Rich middle
class and up because it comes right into
your [ __ ] house and it turns your
kids into breakfast marks as we go I
love the breakfast I love the breakfast
narcs I love it I mean that's what
they're doing in Virginia right here's a
tip line right yeah
it's served up on a platter for
Democrats right totally nothing they can
attack us for Tony that I always sit
there and say God I have I don't need
anything else some reporter asked me do
they need to you know overturn Roe I'm
like no dude did they have to come in
overturn the Second Amendment to make a
gun right you know gun rights
ideological [ __ ] interest group Rich
movement to do electoral politics no
they just pretended it was gonna happen
right right well they still pretend they
still Pretend There's Joe Biden's still
going to take their guns after Obama
took them for eight years I mean this is
all nonsense it's always nonsense with
them that's why they love trumpets
because he played to the house of cards
more than anyone could ever imagine
that's why they they got so infatuated
with him is because he really was
willing to go all in on every [ __ ]
lie they've ever [ __ ] told yes and
not only not only going all in but he
was willing to build the entire party
the entire Administration the entire
country around all these [ __ ] lies
because you know before that Republicans
would only go up to a certain point
right like they always then bailed their
fascism with with conservatism and when
it was Obama it was the tea party and we
don't want debts and all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's all fascism I like uh you
know I harp on Liz Cheney here
everyone's like oh she's gonna save
democracy I'm like that's fine don't
take the shovel out of her hand when
she's digging trumpism's grave I'm good
with that but we need to watch and make
sure she doesn't turn that shovel around
on us because she wants her party back
so that she can sell the thin veil
fascism through conservatism again
because she sees where this road is
headed where Democrats like you and
Stranded just like you are going to take
advantage of the wackadus out there
having control of their messaging in
their party like Matt Matt gatz and
Marjorie Taylor green Jesus Christ Matt
gatz is is being federally investigated
for [ __ ] sex trafficking Miners and
their party's like yeah sure he's on
committees yeah sure he can question the
FBI yeah sure we want him in charge of
messaging that's a good idea let's put
the let's put the [ __ ] chomo in
charge as of [ __ ] messaging let's do
that that's what they're doing and I
can't even I can't even [ __ ]
understand how Democrats on the hill or
anyone else out there
really is so focused on each line item
issue in the build back better which
don't even get me started on how
ridiculous
um the messaging is around buildback
better why we didn't just call it an
education Bill and start there and let
the Republicans fight out all the [ __ ]
that's in it right it tried to tell the
American people why they don't want all
the [ __ ] that they want that's in it
just call it an education bill but
that's neither here nor there but it
just it's so frustrating that not only
the like we were talking about the
people on the hill or the Democratic
machine whatever you want to call it but
it's it's not only that it's it's it's
we got to get to the minds into the
hearts of these voters and get them to
understand that like you said do you
want your family to turn into breakfast
narcs is that what you want do you want
them to go down this road where you're
you're looking around the corner looking
around your shoulder because that's what
happens in authoritarianism they don't
they don't just control sorts of things
they control all of it and that's the
whole point of it that's why they want
to seize power so essentially they are
not the majority in this country of
ideology I don't believe that do you
believe that
no yo I mean here we know what we we
know right right
that's right we ask people are you you
know what's your ideology and they
self-report it and almost you know ever
in the Democratic side especially modal
answer is moderate Republican party
modal answers conservative so there you
go right there's ideology difference
there in asymmetry
um and number two
Republicans are much more much more
proud to say [ __ ] yeah I'm very
conservative okay and and liberals
actually have doubled the amount because
like polarization is asymmetrical it's
way worse on the right but it is there's
things that move on the left okay and
we've seen a doubling of the number of
people who are willing to say I'm very
liberal in the last decade in that data
okay so like there is like a backlash or
a like a you know they they move we move
effect going on but generally speaking
most people will have an ideology
because they don't give a [ __ ] and
that's what you need to have an ideology
right the swing voters like this big
focus group Frank let's just put out
today right like that I mean I don't
even need to hold a [ __ ] focus group
to tell you the results of that focus
group and it's gonna be you can see this
in the data and that's why you know
having voter file data is so powerful
Independents are the people that are
most likely to receive their turnout in
this midterm they of all all the people
who collapse turn out in order
Independence Democrats and then
Republicans Republicans don't collapse
turnout not because they're smarter or
richer or better people than us guys
that's because they have a better
electoral system and it makes sure that
their Coalition end of that system is
always well invested and well built out
ours is completely haphazard and only
now coming onto Line in any regard when
you look at the Virgin or Georgia Senate
races so um you know they have a better
system they're getting better outcomes
they're so they're over represented in
terms of power because especially these
off-year elections which is why Tony and
I keep talking about outrage right you
got to stay [ __ ] pissed and be pissed
at the right people which is not goddamn
Joe Biden who's governing in an
extraordinary time against opposition
that has no incentive to make policy
they're getting more [ __ ] done than you
could ever imagine in the situation that
he's in with only the 50 votes in the
Senate which is because he's not going
to get help from Republicans here
because because they're going 2022 is to
make him look like he's feeble old and
he can't he can't do government right
like that's the whole point and
Democrats are the only ones that can
actually [ __ ] govern like in the
modern history the only the only [ __ ]
party that has ever came into government
and American people have been better off
while and after they've been in power is
the [ __ ] Democrats and the reason why
it's really simple it's not hard to
understand they actually want to do
policy and they want to govern so if
policy is what you want if you want you
know this policy that policy you want
this [ __ ] to change you really you
really need to look at deep down inside
you and say well is is an authoritarian
type party who wants one person in
charge who wants a dictator possibly to
have a fascist state or do you want
people who are pro-democracy or who are
willing to actually do the hard because
it's [ __ ] hard work it ain't easy to
do policy it is not because we do not
[ __ ] agree and and you know everyone
says that's a downfall to the Democratic
party that all their Coalition is made
up of so many different people I'm like
that's the good part like what are you
talking about we're we're [ __ ] huge
our Coalition is [ __ ] huge we can
bury these people in mountains of votes
every single election if we just had the
Strategic outrage we just stayed pissed
every single [ __ ] cycle and we go
[ __ ] vote because frankly at this
point Democrats are the only ones that
deliver in this country for democracy
and Republicans want to destroy
democracy so what is your choice I guess
that's where I fall on it no [ __ ] and
let me just tell you one more thing too
like there's this perception and people
read political science literature we
write literature in poli-sci that goes
into journals in this peer review to be
kind of
absolutist-ish about its findings so
people say okay well the Republicans
have an ideological Coalition and
they're rallying around ideology and
Democrats are group group interested in
them of course I'm the person teaches
you that right right that's [ __ ] true
God eyes but that doesn't mean that
Democrats have no ideology and and
Republicans have no factualism what
Republicans did after the Tea Party took
over now granted like some of this rules
into like those people's seizing control
of the party is that they just decided
you know at some point
all out
and do [ __ ] policy right we are
organized
Oregon volition right so like all the
coalitions of Republican politics might
care about [ __ ] but the thing they care
about above every [ __ ] thing else is
killing us right own the libs own the
libs well I mean it's been it's been
it's become their entire uh political
identity yeah and and listen Tony we can
[ __ ] about that right I mean right so
like I want to be [ __ ] really clear
about something because I took on
dissertation on polarization because I
committed I feel all the feels that
people feel on the left about this [ __ ]
okay I want to be really clear about
that but at the end of the day guys when
your other the other system is going to
hit us right
um you know in the local paper here for
the competitive race here in Oregon for
what did the GOP nominee who ran last
time say he said I don't give a [ __ ] who
the who the nominee is it could be
moderate and more moderate Progressive
Val Hoyle or it could be someone from
the far left doesn't matter because I'm
going to Brand them all the same I'm
gonna make them own their shitty party
that's literally what the quote says
right right that's branding and that is
what I am arguing we need to be doing
and if we are failing to fill that
atmosphere if we're defending [ __ ] if
we're explaining [ __ ] or like oh no we
don't really feel like that or the
policy doesn't really do that we're
gonna [ __ ] lose okay so like let's
separate the policy argument the
inclination to get on TV and give
substantive deep like really like
sincere answers because we have to
[ __ ] win we have to win so get on
there and when they ask you about
failing build back better her then use
it you bring up repeal and replace right
pivot and attack right [ __ ] failures
they ran off for the decade dude right
and still couldn't get it done couldn't
get it done
so bad and I'll be like you want to ask
me about build bag better after I passed
you know blah blah blah blah blah blah
when these [ __ ] can't even
repeal and replace Obamacare when
they've made it their entire [ __ ]
platform for a day well [ __ ] they not
only try to repeal replace they tried to
destroy it through the Supreme Court
they tried to destroy it with executive
orders and cause people to die we've
never [ __ ] to check for that oh I'm
saying Tony is trying to send some
[ __ ] checks
it's time to cash in huh we had to ask
ask them to pay some [ __ ] bills we
don't have to worry about what they're
gonna do next they've done enough guys
and they made Benghazi the key issue of
an election cycle four [ __ ] years
after the event okay it happened in
2012. right we have we have some
comments here that I want to show you um
Yoda says oh my God Rachel bittick offer
I am fangirling out now uh and MJ says
hi Rachel
um I want Rachel sake politics girl and
Porter to run the world yeah let's do
that let's get let's get let's get
Rachel and and Katie Porter's whiteboard
together and let's see let's see how
they [ __ ] like that [ __ ] right pivot
and attack right
so so we do have we do have have one uh
kind of a question here we need to get
uh to reach out to younger Generations
Millennials and gen z
um you know that's that's one thing like
that's one thing that they never do like
they don't ever divide up their
electorate like oh well we need to reach
out to older folks we need to reach it
like they're just like no we're gonna
reach out to everyone and we're gonna
try to we're gonna try to get them to
believe in the [ __ ] we believe and like
you said we're going to get them to own
the libtards right like that's their
whole thing we don't we we can reach out
to Millennials we can reach out to gen Z
but it doesn't have to be like a focused
it just can be strategic outrage
throughout the whole freaking map we can
stay pissed we can go vote and we can
make sure that our message speaks to all
Americans not just one not just this one
you know I think that's sometimes when
they have the challenges you know
they're they're dancing around these
issues
um and trying to figure out the exact
line item and the bill that they're
gonna support when they become Congress
well [ __ ] go be a member of Congress
first and then sort out the [ __ ] line
item that you want in the bill for your
constituents that and Republicans do
because they don't have a policy they
don't have any what do they [ __ ] run
on what is it taking away people's
Liberty I mean come on
in policies I mean repeal and replace
right they could never do that they had
never had a plan
because the Obamacare package the ACA is
their [ __ ] right it is their bill
right it's their bill like we forgot
that like it's been so many years that
we forget that Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
with the help of Ted Kennedy passed that
bill in Massachusetts and then they're
like Obama's like copy [ __ ] paste
that's what I'm saying why couldn't
Obama just once have been like [ __ ]
it's your bill
well well if you go back if you go back
as far as the 2008 campaign between John
McCain and and Barack Obama really if
you look at the ACA and you compare it
to what those two candidates were
campaigning on that [ __ ] ACA plan
looks more like what the hell John
McCain was talking about than what the
[ __ ] Obama was talking about during the
campaign it looks way more like what
because it's scary right exactly exactly
I mean the movie is literally like a
private sector I mean it's the per I
mean actually you know what it's not the
best for Health Options it's better than
the the previous system right right but
at the end of the [ __ ] day like it
there's no uh there's no way to do
Health Care reform that's more private
sector friendly right right and we
killed we lost the messaging on that you
should have seen that I'm not gonna tell
who you guys who this was but it was a
pretty important person with a lot of
like influencer top-down framing ability
and you know I I suggested I said why
didn't you guys just run on Obamacare it
[ __ ] insured 30 million people and
then they didn't die right so just find
a couple that didn't die and make some
ads
like it never [ __ ] occurred to them
like oh if they run against Obamacare
and pick out the [ __ ] website to harp
on and then we get defensive then we
lose right right because we're fighting
we're fighting in the space so the
website sucks and that has nothing to do
with the bill right no doubt and like
they and then they go and they figure
out like eventually over time and it's
just so painful to be me right so like
they figure out over time finally oh
turns out when you ask people about the
individual components they like it they
don't [ __ ] like that [ __ ] right and I
don't like this because
it's quite care well you know that's why
they
Republicans named it Obamacare if you
want to [ __ ] kill a GOP policy name
it the Trump tax plan right right right
right right right right
like I just you know at the end of the
day they make their Fortune right they
wanted they knew Clinton was likely to
be the nominee in 16. they knew that
after getting disrupted by Obama there's
no way the party is going to do it twice
to her right she's in 60 approval
Secretary of State killing the [ __ ]
job it's two years after Benghazi okay
right and that's right okay let's figure
it out and she put that [ __ ] to bed she
put the Benghazi shoes oh [ __ ] and it
doesn't even matter right like they did
eight nine ten whatever select
committees until they found that [ __ ]
email thing right and we like you know I
mean oh I just I I could forgive the
media less about like apparently
sleeping on the lead context that in
half of the Republican party at the
state level at all of the federal levels
in the judicial system and the doj
conspired to steal the election and they
were only sorted by luck basically right
and like there's no conversation about
that but we [ __ ] know everything
about Clinton's private I could tell you
everything you want to know about that
private service
well I I mean and that's what they do I
mean they're still bitching about
Hillary Clinton on Fox news they still
[ __ ] about a certain person's laptop I
mean literally the the former
president's son is on a [ __ ] cocaine
Bender uh uh posting videos about how
he's going to take over the world and
how they're going to take over the world
and [ __ ] Hunter Biden is nowhere to be
found Republicans are paying two
thousand dollars to take a [ __ ]
picture with booger sugar Junior right
no Democrat in the [ __ ] country is
lining up to meet Hunter Biden not
[ __ ] one of them not one of them but
they keep harping on it they're obsessed
with Dr fauci this is the [ __ ] that they
do and I'm and I think I'm saying it and
you're saying it this is the [ __ ] we can
do we don't have to use misinformation
and [ __ ] lies it's really easy when
it's right out in front of you you have
like you said you have these [ __ ]
whack-a-doo criminals running the
Republican party why in the [ __ ] can't
we go hey look at them all the
Republicans are just like them if they
got an R next to the name that's who the
[ __ ] they are that's what they want
let's pin them up like the guy what what
uh make them own their own [ __ ] party
right make them own it make them oh [ __ ]
and then when you fail to [ __ ] do
that then you end up with a Beltway
Narrative of how oh well look at
he won't let Trump come to Virginia so
therefore he's rejecting Trump no dude
he's got half the [ __ ] guy's platform
he's giving lip service to election you
know um you know his election conspiracy
[ __ ] before the election even happens so
like basically prepping his loss right
right so he's obviously not a Democrat
small D Democrat because you don't
[ __ ] do that right you believe in
democracy and then he gets into office I
was the first thing he does he goes full
[ __ ] Rhonda Sanders and all I wanted
to do in Virginia six months out I was
like look this is what's going to be
like what what the fall will look like
we've got CRT thing coming down
let's [ __ ] Hammer this theme that
young can this is not change that you
want Republican change in 22 21 in
Virginia 22 here is not to change you
voter it could be fill in the blank
voter is going or going to launch
because it is going to wreak havoc on
your economics on your health on your
kids future and whatever else is you
know a perfectly or uh especially
pertinent to that voter right but you
can't make it it it can't just ignore
this giant you know uh aspect of it and
and pretend I hope it's just going to go
away well I really appreciate you coming
we've had we've had about a 30-minute
conversation I think I took more your
your your time than I had asked for so I
appreciate you coming on you're welcome
back every single week any any time that
you want just just send me a message say
hey I got something I want to talk about
and we'll get on here and we'll rant and
Rave and we can go after this these
folks and maybe we can teach some people
how to how to frame up the messaging
because literally we are in a situation
where Democrats are the only party that
are going to deliver democracy in this
country like you said in Virginia
um California thank God that recall
happened the way we needed it to but
2022 is going to be important because
Democrats are the only one that want to
deliver democracy Republicans want to
destroy it so we have to stay pissed we
have to go [ __ ] vote and the way that
we get out the vote and pile up
mountains and mountains of ballots on
top of these son of a [ __ ] and fascist
is that we have to have strategic
outrage and we have to stay in that
mindset so Rachel where where can
everyone find find you at on Twitter and
and strike pack tell them real quick
before we before we let you go where do
they find you so they can start this
process of learning what that strategic
outrage is yeah have you follow me on on
Twitter at Rachel bittacoffer and um go
to strike pack check out our ads some of
these ads are all the ads are teaching
ads basically I mean they they get
deployed or they'll be deployed in ways
too but they're also designed to teach
people like this is how the GOP does
their messaging they don't they don't
they aren't looking at the voter file
and saying oh there's a base
mobilization pool and a persuasion pool
and we should argue about policy that's
popular that poll tests well with that
persuasion pool like that's not how the
GOP runs their messaging they don't run
their targeting the same way either at
the end of the day the deployment of
elect of these electoral tactics and we
want
um you know people to learn about more
about that they can read my article in
this in Salon about it too that kind of
breaks down Those ads and explains how
they're performing that that function of
modernizing our messaging approach well
thank you Rachel I appreciate you
joining us everyone stay stay with us we
will go to the [ __ ] list Roundup right
after this break thanks Rachel
you sit your ass down flip now
we're not finished the Tony Michaels
podcast we'll be right back
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
[Music]
the Tony Michaels podcast Wednesdays at
4 pm Eastern 3 P.M Central watch live on
YouTube on Twitter and twitch download
on Apple and Spotify now here's Tony
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the Show
podcast it is Wednesday I need to change
my commercial there it still says
Wednesday I forgot to do that Ipsy
oopsie yeah you [ __ ] up every once in a
while what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do we're
gonna go to the [ __ ] list Roundup
there's a lot of stuff on the trendy
Trends and the tweezers we've had you
guys like Rachel coming in today uh
we're trying to get her more and more on
the show um go follow Rachel at Rachel
bittickoffer on Twitter it's
r-a-c-h-e-l-b-i-t-e-c-o-f-e-r Rachel
bite Coffer if you want to spell it out
like that
um you gotta go follow her over there
like she said watch the commercials that
are they're they're trying to teach you
this strategic outrage thing and also go
subscribe to the YouTube channel because
the the uh interview that we did with
Rachel me and Gabe did with Rachel a
couple weeks ago is over there on its
own or you can watch the podcast with it
on there just go to the YouTube page
um and you can find the Rachel but to
Coffer interview
it's a really good interview she breaks
down more of this strategic outrage
everyone's saying she's awesome we love
her yes Rachel is is [ __ ] awesome she
does not give a [ __ ] um she definitely
has the [ __ ] him attitude so we really
like that here on I think Tony Michaels
podcast
um let's see what do we what do we have
today
um that's that's queued up for the tree
Tweety tweets and Trinity Trends uh Kid
Rock is being compared to Willie Nelson
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
um we've got Michael Rapaport Nina
Turner is running uh again
um against uh Chantelle Brown I think of
Chantelle Brown we have Jordan Peterson
um on Joe Rogan's podcast and we have
Colin Kaepernick is trending I'm not
real sure why but uh I could probably I
could probably guess so um let's start
the countdown and let's start the
shitless Roundup
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
up
[Music]
uh we we started [ __ ] list around the
bright late because we had Rachel
bittickoffer on the show
um it looks like we have someone joining
us now oh hey Gabe oh you're Beauty your
fans your fans are gonna be happy that
you're here they missed you yesterday
they were sad you didn't come yesterday
so I figured another one yeah I figured
I would hop in for a few say hello you
know okay okay right what's going on
right right right as I start the [ __ ]
list Roundup here that's yeah have you
been on have you been on Twitter this
morning yet and looking at the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends I've seen a
few things obviously the biggest news
that just came out in the last like 15
minutes yeah what's going on over there
was uh Supreme Court some changes
happening going over there we got
retirement happening oh really yeah oh
wow so I'm gonna have some [ __ ] to to
run down the list here then oh did you
not know about this I did not know about
this oh yeah you are breaking news here
on the Tony Michaels podcast what what
the hell look okay well let's let's do
this let's go over here real quick to
the uh the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trend yeah it should be there right at
the top let's see let's go uh Stephen
Breyer yeah that sounds sounds like
something's going on with Stephen Breyer
what what's going on here Associated
Press says breaking Justice Stephen
Breyer is retiring from the Supreme
Court the vacancy created by the liberal
judge gives Biden the first High Court
pick of his presidency so um it looks
like um the news that you're reporting
is is that Joe Biden with a Democratic
Senate uh thanks to Republicans for
carving out the filibuster for Supreme
Court Justices are going to be able to
Ram through any [ __ ] Justice that
they want yeah hey [ __ ] men and I
hope I hope they pick the youngest most
liberal [ __ ] that they can find
I don't give a [ __ ] who it is I don't
give a [ __ ] who it is the most liberal
young I mean that way they can serve for
like 60 years on that son of what is the
age requirement I don't even know do you
know uh I don't know if there is an a
like a Max or a mini mean
huh well I mean no no like do you have
to be a certain angel you have to be a
certain age run for president run for
that right right
age requirements obviously not specify
qualification for justice such as
education profession or native Warren
citizenship
oh so so a Justice could essentially be
you know like in their 30s or something
maybe you should maybe you should uh
campaign to be the uh Supreme Court
Justice well uh you know I would but it
says justice does not have oh it does
not have to be a lawyer or a law school
graduate that's right they have no but I
have to be trained in the law
you're basically an expert right I've
been trained in uh internet laws so
that's okay well well yeah so so what
what's your opinion of uh obviously this
is probably good news for most Democrats
out there that they're seeing that
um Justice Stephen Breyer is because
they do this to Ruth Bader Ginsburg they
say oh she should have retired years ago
in Obama so he could pick
um and obviously maybe maybe that's
affecting uh Stephen Breyer's decision
here
um possibly I don't know if that's the
case or not but now you got some fans
here hi Gabe they're they're all they're
all yeah uh yeah I don't know here's uh
best case scenario we're able to just
follow what Mitch McConnell did the
Republicans in his jam it through Sans
uh a coveted super spreader event uh but
if we you know know worst case scenario
is Mitch McConnell somehow finds a way
to push this out past the midterms and
I'm really hoping that doesn't happen
well so I I think I think that's a good
point and it's probably the worry on on
most people's minds but here's the great
part about if Democrats grow a set of
nuts here and do what they should do
which is [ __ ] you you did it you did it
two weeks before the election right [ __ ]
right when right before it was oh we
can't do it because we're in the same
year as an election for Obama and he was
like
okay fine I mean also how we got
ourselves our current attorney general
um because he was unable to become
Supreme Court Justice because of people
like [ __ ]
uh Mitch McConnell and the rest of those
yeah yeah I mean I mean man they they
you know they bitched last week about
carving out the rule for voting rights
for all Americans and and just after and
this is not just mansion and Cinema
every single Republican got up and
harped on carving out the rules to make
sure that Americans received the right
to vote
but but they carved out the Supreme
Court rule so that way they could Jam
Amy Coney Barrett down our throat I mean
Kathy Griffin even says your Supreme
Court Justice Stephen Breyer just
announced his retirement can we please
get a female woman of color who is the
same age as Amy Coney Barrett thanks I I
totally agree I think I think I think we
should get the I think they should Biden
should pick the pick that pisses them
off the [ __ ] most [ __ ] them I mean at
this point at this point it's it's worth
sending the political message that hey
we're not toying around with this
Supreme Court thing when we get picks
we're picking I saw someone I saw
someone online that said Anita Hill
should be at the pick uh which would be
very interesting that would be very
interesting that would be a a
drama-filled bench right right but you
know
um
one of our favorite heroism says mike
Lindell this is a quote president
Trump will Point Cindy Powell to replace
Steven Breyer by Valentine's Day
I'm sure I you know what's funny about
this quote hoodlum is
this is something that could be real
like this could you know like oh
absolutely like he's gonna be prisoner
by September 89th and he'll he'll he'll
take power and I feel like Mike Lindell
picks a he picks a holiday on the
calendar and then says that is the day
in which this big event's gonna happen
and then it you know it's like right
it's like the worst no Nostradamus and
they like the worst at it like most of
them are like dumbass
trying to pick like dates that are far
out right there right like they really
try to give it like three or four years
at least to really try to make sure to
stoke these people into this into this
frenzy but literally like before he can
blow up the balloon the balloon's
running around the room in the fart you
know the fart Bloom right right it's
like uh he'd be like oh you know it's
gonna happen on February 29th and then
complete forgets that it's leap year you
know right right right right right right
right it's like [ __ ] uh this [ __ ] gay
this [ __ ] gay thank you for your
Tweet yeah who loves always get the good
ones doesn't it okay okay let's see what
else we got here coach we got all the
the news reports here uh but we it looks
it looks like it's confirmed that he's
retiring
um so who who do you think who do you
think could be I mean do you have
someone on your list do you think oh I
have no idea you know who I would want
you know who I would want oh I mean I'm
just I'm just throwing out a couple
names here dude what are you gonna say
Michelle Obama no oh well I mean that
could be a name but I I think I think
her husband Barack Obama would make a
great Supreme Court Justice oh yeah um I
think I think I think that would be I
mean can you imagine can you oh I can
imagine oh my God Tucker Carlson's
panties would set right on [ __ ] fire
oh my God yeah and I'm sure
this never happened before you can't do
this and it's like yeah sure I mean it
probably won't happen but at the same
time there's no rule that doesn't can
happen right right it says a president
can't be vice president you know the one
that probably isn't a great pick
um because you know because she is older
but the one that would really I mean
absolutely collapse make them collapse
is if Hillary Clinton was the nominee oh
I mean oh my God it would just be like
oh you know what you know what you know
what Joe Biden should do here's what I
think he should do and maybe we should
campaign for this game maybe we should
put this out there in the Twitter sphere
here I think the person that would be
the absolute best nominee for Supreme
Court Justices Hunter Biden's laptop I
actually think that would probably be
the actual pick that we need is Hunter
by Design because you know Democrats
love Hunter Biden's laptop like oh yeah
yeah absolutely obsessed with it I would
love to see Hunter Biden's laptop on a
zoom call you know right where it's like
Hey listen I don't want to get covered
computer at back at do you think do you
think Hunter Biden's laptop would be a
dick like Gorsuch and not wear a mask to
like the proceedings uh
laptop that much of an [ __ ] I mean I
don't know I mean I've he's I feel like
the the laptop is like very ominous like
we hear these things but it hasn't been
confirmed right it's like it's like
there's just like this
spectral beam that's out there
I love how we're pretending that Hunter
bike laptop is an extra person no there
wasn't there was a point in the back of
my head which is is is kind of crazy
because it would never happen
but right now you look at
um you look at how obviously Republicans
hate
um Harris for obvious reasons right you
know she's a woman or she's a woman of
color right see I need help uh um Robin
says Anita Hill here it would be kind of
crazy if
uh
if somehow they were like all right cool
we're gonna like some shift happened and
of course it would be crazy like it
would have to happen mid term but if
they were like oh uh Harris becomes
uh scotus and then there's a new VP that
comes in
um which
you know I don't know I that would be it
would be crazy I don't think it would
happen but I could see both sides of the
argument where it's like oh she's
younger she's a woman of color uh so
you're so you're you're you're maybe
maybe putting your hat in the ring for
some sort of vice presidential
um
I mean like I feel like she would
I feel like she would be a good
candidate potentially I don't know I
mean she's not obviously super like
Progressive uh in that sense so like it
might you know she might toe the middle
of the line if anything right but um you
could have people on both sides like oh
this is great so we can actually get
someone who is more Progressive as a VP
then some people would be like
Republicans would say oh great yeah
um
clearly it's a failed Administration so
if you have to you know take her out but
it's like you know I don't know if
you're thinking long term it's like
what's the position you're trying to put
them in right like you only you're only
guaranteed another three years of this
Administration right how do you make an
impact for more than three years right
well one one way is to pick a Supreme
Court Justice that you're not going to
cow down to the whole oh well they're
bipartisan and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] we played that game we played that
game with these [ __ ] with Merrick
Garland
um years ago and they absolutely you
know of course they were going to be
Hypocrites about this thing but they
absolutely you know discounted all that
so why why should we go down that road
again so I think it would be a big
mistake at the administration even
considers someone who's a moderate or or
in that in that lane as such [ __ ] that
[ __ ] get the most liberal youngest uh
and I I think you're right a woman of
color and Kathy's right too
um because I think I think that's the
way that the country goes because I
actually think that's what our
leadership looks like in the future now
in the next generation is women of color
and it and that's what really terrifies
these [ __ ] Tucker Carlson Alpha Cooks
right like they're [ __ ] completely
terrified that women of color will
actually be governing them because they
feel like oh my God what if what if they
oppress us the way that we want to
oppress them that'll be horrible right
and and you know the the secret is that
black people in this country you're just
lucky they don't want revenge they
actually just want equality and Equity
right you know the other the other thing
too is is how
um
uh
uh like with any good team right you
work on or any good leadership team
especially you know in Corporate America
like the best
uh the best
kind of
movements that are made or or growth
that is made within a company are done
by those that are a representation of
the people they serve right that they
represent and so if you've got a person
of color uh you know a a person who's
younger person who's older a person
who's white you know like a wide range
right you want an Eclectic mix of people
who are smart and talented but also come
from a wide range of experiences in in
life uh you know and upbringings and and
uh geopolitical status and all these
different things because at the end of
the day if you have the same white old
man on a bench or in a boardroom they're
gonna make the same decision over and
over again and not learn from there as
opposed to having a diverse collection
of ideas and opinions and ways to
approach a case in this instance where
they would say actually this would be uh
so [ __ ] up right or this would be
great if it was done or whatever like
whatever their actual kind of opinion or
position is
um you get the best ideas and the best
outcome from a diverse that's why I mean
like when you look at Democrats it's
like well why is this group so much
better than Republicans is because
they're not making the same mistake
whether intentionally or unintentionally
because they've got different people
coming in that's like uh no that doesn't
work anymore or you know what actually
based on my life based on my experience
or based on the constituents that
constituents that I represent this is
actually what needs to be said well you
know that that's a good point because me
and Rachel um earlier in the show we
were talking about Democrats being this
big tent and everyone thinks that that's
like a downfall like no what the [ __ ]
are you talking about like that's the
whole point is to build a huge Coalition
now is it challenging sometimes to get
that Coalition behind one message and
one goal yeah but right now it should be
really [ __ ] easy like like we have no
better time than these clowns because
the way they're good the way they're
going to respond to just Justice Stephen
Breyer stepping down they are gonna
tonight on Fox News they're going to be
burning down the house like they're they
are going to be [ __ ] terrified here
because here's what Amy Says and this is
why they're going to be terrified
breaking Supreme Court Justice Stephen
Breyer is retiring per NBC News which
will give President Biden a critical
opportunity to replace him with another
liberal Justice right so they're going
to be absolutely [ __ ] terrified
terrified the good news is is we're not
into the election cycle quite yet like
we haven't been through any primaries
yet
um so if Biden can make this pick and um
which I'm sure because this isn't like
um a death of a Justice where you know
you kind of have to step back and
respect you know
um and give give the justice that has
died their peace right no he's retiring
did someone give that piece to well I
mean you think you would if you were a
[ __ ] decent human being but they are
not decent human beings here I mean
we're not dealing we're not dealing with
with [ __ ] people who have souls I
mean if we look at uh uh if we look at
during Obama's presidency right like you
had I don't know somewhat less than a
year right before the election was done
and they're like well no we can't make a
big decision like that when uh the
presidency is up for you know the the
election
um is up
uh uh uh that's upcoming right like we
can't make a big decision like that uh
you know and we have to let the people
decide right so they hold off they push
it right and then it's in election a big
[ __ ] election 2020 and then we're
like what a month out we're you know
October and they're like okay yeah let's
just like pump this bad boy through and
it's like whoa whoa didn't you just say
last the for the last president that
literally had this happen to you guys
said no we can't do this and now you
want to do this well that's what they're
gonna say again right and it's like
literally what they're going to say like
by this afternoon they're going to be
saying you can't do this during an
election year like they're going and
they're gonna pound that drum because
they have no [ __ ] bones about winning
and that's and that's honestly what the
Democrats need to start doing they need
to start [ __ ] having no bones about
winning now we don't have to use
misinformation and lies and all the
[ __ ] we don't have to do that the
truth is on our side the majority
Authority the American people want what
Democrats you know Big D and small D
Democrats want I mean they want
pro-democracy they want they want to get
[ __ ] done on issues like health care and
education and wages and and housing they
want to do all those [ __ ] things they
want to do all those things but the only
party that is willing to do it is the
Democratic party they're the only ones
that deliver Republicans want to destroy
everything and you will watch them
absolutely act like this country is
going to be destroyed if Joe Biden
replaces a liberal Justice with another
liberal Justice like literally that's
what we're talking about we are not
talking about a conservative Justice
here that's being replaced by a liberal
Justice we're talking about keeping the
vote the exact same right there is there
is no the only good thing about this is
that we're not going to have the Crypt
Keeper as the Supreme Court Justice
right we can actually pick someone who's
young who's vibrant who can go in who
can fight and make sure that they they
they had hold to the Constitution and
the American people not this [ __ ]
where they're bought and paid for by
some [ __ ] special interest group and
they get they get their debt paid off to
become a Supreme Court Justice still
wondering who paid off uh Kavanaugh's
debt just saying right anyone if anyone
has the answer please come to us yeah
right Democrat can do this Democrats can
do this
um and they can do it well and they can
just ignore all the [ __ ] noise about
oh you're trying to destroy our country
like we're replacing a liberal Justice
with a liberal Justice right sit down
and shut the [ __ ] up but I can't wait to
hear that later today I mean like it's
probably already happening right now
where the people are you know Fox News
and all of them are going to say you
can't do this and despite the fact that
when you said we couldn't do it then you
came back in a in a much a fraction of
the time before for an election and said
because here's the thing it wasn't even
like when Obama was President it was
like oh well he's not up for re-election
right like it was it was uh uh it was
for uh right wasn't it two thousand
it happened before right when uh
who are you talking about
uh because
it was his second term where he tried to
put uh Garland in right yeah yeah well
it was it was yeah it was the it was uh
it was the year before it was 2016. the
cycle had not happened yet right right
or was it 20 was it the end of 2015 or
right in 2016 right right and and then
the cycle had not happened yet they had
almost over a year
um to seat uh Supreme Court Justice
right and the Republicans wouldn't even
and because they controlled the Senate
right wouldn't even hold meetings with
Merrick Garland right you know and and
Obama tried to pick mayor Garland in a
way to you know basically have you know
cow Tao to the the conservatives in that
he's not really he wasn't a conservative
Justice he wasn't a liberal Justice I
mean you know then frankly mayor Garland
um I I think he's more apolitical just
because of his career yeah that's been
in front of him
um but and maybe that'll show through as
him as attorney general for Department
of Justice is maybe we'll be very happy
that he wasn't
um named the Supreme Court Justice not
that there couldn't be anyone else do
the job of Attorney General at this
point so I expect I wouldn't be
surprised I'll probably write some
sketch about this about just the basic
it's just going to be a conversation
it's going to be so [ __ ] dumb where
it's like we want Supreme Court no you
can't have it right why can't we have it
because an election year okay fine
whatever well what about the highest
order right oh we want a supreme court
what you guys you said last year that we
couldn't have it right and then it's
like you guys are you guys are
witnessing Gabe right right the video
right here in front it's like you guys
sent the president no we didn't yes you
did that's fake news that it's literally
what you guys said right it's like you
can already see this conversation you
already he's gonna go back and forth and
they're like Justice Prior you know you
only have to guess what the [ __ ] these
guys are gonna say and that's that's the
that's the point that me and Rachel were
trying to make in the last segment is
that on this issue alone like this issue
alone you don't have to [ __ ] guess
what they're gonna say we shouldn't have
to guess what we're gonna say like
literally like okay yeah we're gonna
replace a liberal Justice who's retiring
with another liberal Justice who's
younger that's that's the thing that's
what we're gonna do and we're gonna keep
the vote the exact same in the Supreme
Court and I think that's the that's the
you know to what Yuji said is adding on
to what Amy said here is like it's not
just a another liberal Justice right
because then it's like okay whatever
it's a younger liberate Justice because
right now right you know there are no
term limits for supreme Supreme Court
Justice there there are uh no
restrictions as to how long they can
serve unless something happens right uh
or or they uh retire resign so I think
that's the biggest
um that's the biggest point right there
which is
a younger a younger liberal Justice
because they're going in I mean I don't
know how long is or how old is Amy Comey
bear like 30 some late 30s early 40s I
you know I I don't know I don't know how
old she is I know uh I know how old she
wants to be like she wants to be in her
[ __ ] 80s you know like Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ lady she is uh
49 okay almost 50. yeah I mean I I
wouldn't be opposed to having someone in
the early 40s yeah that's fine too but
that's the thing I think oh we want to
get someone in their lifetime which is
like you know you're looking at 49
you know 30 more years maybe of this
person on the on the bench potentially
so it's like you're trying to find
someone that's going to be able to
uh put a stamp on
uh on Court decisions that you know rule
the land of America right like you want
to put them in a position that that puts
others uh in a in a well
uh a strong point right going forward
you don't want to have to like take away
the rights take away this and that like
it's something that's that's going to be
the biggest thing which is
um
you want that's I think that's what's
gonna that's what's gonna upset them the
most is the fact that it's a younger
person that potentially a younger
liberal yeah I open I hope it's I hope
it's they're younger I hope they're a
woman
um I I think that's what needs to happen
I think I think there's gonna be no one
um in this country especially if it's a
woman of color
um that's going to help protect people's
rights
um
um not not just not not just people of
color but all people's rights because
that's that's where it needs to swing
down because I think they understand the
the ramifications when uh not just a
woman but also a woman of color
um when they start to take away your
[ __ ] Liberties how it affects a
person because
um people of color and women are the
first ones they [ __ ] start taking
them away from uh the prime example is
Texas and Mississippi so you have
someone who has a voice to represent
that population right right now you live
out in L.A um I guess today is the
second anniversary of Kobe Bryant's
death and the horrific uh helicopter
crash
um it is trending because of that
um are they are they having big things
out there today or something I I don't I
haven't read down this thread possibly I
know that whole situation I'm like I was
on set that day when that happened and
everyone just like stopped and it was
like whoa you know what's going on and
they're like because these are very it
was a very strange thing yeah it was
like early afternoon when it like
dropped on Twitter and I was like what
is going you know everyone's like what
the [ __ ] going on and it was released
that Kobe Bryant you know was on this
helicopter and then like more details
came out and it was like holy [ __ ] like
this is crazy and obviously his wife you
know is going through a whole lawsuit
right now because photos were released
um by the county sheriff I think it was
like they went out there took photos and
then that got leaked you mean you mean
of the of the crash of the crash site
yeah so like don't respect just like
money grab kind of situation right and I
think she's
I mean I I so is that still ongoing then
uh I feel like that but you know the the
shocking thing that day and what it made
it I mean obviously it's Kobe Bryant but
it made it so strange as the story of of
uh him and his daughter being an
helicopter and some other parents and
they were flying to I guess basketball
practice or something and of course yeah
the conspiracy theories uh immediately
start to spin
um almost [ __ ] immediately and you
know fingers start to get pointed
everywhere
um you know especially when you have a
person with such a name like Kobe Bryant
his family trying to trying to with him
and his daughter pass away in the
helicopter crash not just him yeah
uh so there are two things is the trial
is nearing so it's coming up I guess
gotcha okay um so I've got a buddy who
is a helicopter pilot uh in in the Navy
and this
before covid we were able to meet up and
we were talking about
um this like what had happened right
because I was like I just want like from
from just known person like I have a
basic understanding of what happened the
fog was dense it was you know difficult
whatever and he was like so it's called
Uh which you hear it in other other
places too it's called um is is it's
called a Swiss cheese Theory I think is
what it's called Uh or just swiss cheese
uh but basically it's like so like swiss
cheese right you've got holes and once
you go through one hole there's gonna be
another hole somewhere else but that
hole might be smaller so you're trying
to navigate through small Pockets right
and that's what happened in the fog
you know as a pilot you're making you
know split-second decisions and so
you're like great I'm gonna navigate
through here but the fog was so dense
where they were traveling or where they
were flying and so it's like okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and fly I'm making a
decision I'm gonna try I Fly Above it
but like I'm not able to break through
anything to see any sort of clearing
so you're making these decisions where
you keep going through and it's like
keeps getting more narrow and narrow and
narrow up until the point at which like
you have no idea where you are then
there's also the sense of like because I
can only see white or like this gray I
can't see any sort of landmark or ground
I have no idea where I am outside of the
the readings that are there and some
people will lose a sense of themselves
uh at the right so they're just they're
kind of lost in the situation right
they're literally lost in the clouds
right and so that's what happened
whereas like you he was making decision
and it was one decision and another and
another assistant and like these were uh
making it more and more difficult to get
out of the situation because he wasn't
able to identify where he was
at that at that point right like and
then obviously it led to a crash
um unfortunately but that's you know
what they what when I was talking to him
he was like that's pretty much what
happened which is like they have you
know it's not uncommon
for Pilots to find themselves in the
situation it's just like how you get
yourself out of it right
um so yeah especially because like they
left out of the like I don't live too
far from the Burbank Airport and I
believe that's where they took off from
which is like 20 minutes from me
and then there you know then basically
what they're traveling is north
Northwest of the airport and they're
just trying to make it through dense
clouds and it was just like
bad bad bad news of course Merrick
Garland is trending here as well I don't
mean to skip over this so so the Kobe
thing um two-year anniversary it sounds
like his wife is finally going to see
her day in court over the pictures but
uh Merrick Garland is trending it looks
like for a couple different things but
obviously the Supreme Court some people
want some people want Joe Biden to pick
him again I'm like oh my God people can
we just stay one one [ __ ] one list at
a time this is you know this is the [ __ ]
that we do that gets us in trouble I
think Michelle Obama Oh I thought she
was trending Let me refresh here she was
I saw
yeah I've seen that too um and I'm sure
it's because of the uh maybe she moved
up the list here no wait go down
there's uh where was she Michael
Rapaport
are you running the show or am I no I'm
just kidding Mary Garland oh man I've
seen it I feel like when there's any
political position that is like up for
grabs everyone's like Michelle Obama
which is like I think you know she'd be
great in the sense of like holding a
position of influence and power and
doing what's right for people you know
um it looks like people are uh how do
you say her name
um I don't want to say it wrong but I'm
gonna say it wrong they're uh Brown
Jackson here
um katanji I I don't know tanji I think
that's it katanji um Brown Jackson
um I I don't know who this is they they
much obviously they sit on the federal
she sits on the federal bench but some
people are suggesting her
um I don't know maybe that's a decent
pick
um
we got some here Briar stepping down
here are your names
Jackson uh Krueger so Jackson is in the
DC Court yeah katanji Brown Jackson yep
how long has she been oh I don't know
how long she's been serving but
I I don't I don't know she uh um
Ella here has has that she's on the DC
Court
um there's uh Leandra uh Krueger which
is on the California Supreme Court which
is uh in your neck of the woods and then
Michelle Childs which is on the South
Carolina District Court which um the
first um one would be uh federal court
the second one I believe is federal
court and the third one is not exactly a
federal court so
um looks like uh people are already
naming yeah some names out there now
rather Biden actually even picks yeah I
was gonna the other thing too is like
let's let's keep in mind that like when
you go into an Administration you've got
you have already have lists ready right
like you're like in the event that this
happens this is who we want to go for
right
and those might change based on events
that happen here and there right but for
the most part uh
they've got they've probably got a short
list ready to go you know well here's
here's a Joy Reed
um talking about this
um
katanji I happen to know katanji
North kitten brown but we were college
so I think she's wonderful and she
actually made it to the top three it was
it was it was her Merrick Garland and
sris Nissan they were the like top three
choices for the scotus and President
Obama chose Garland so so there that
that's what Joy is reporting so I don't
I don't know if um you know I I I'd have
to verify that but I'm sure Joy is on
top of that that she would be on the
high list when Obama was picking Merrick
Garland when the Republicans wouldn't
even give him
um the time of day to even get give them
a meeting do you think do you think uh
just for shits and giggles Biden will
put Ted Cruz on unless Justified
no I think that would be pretty funny
maybe that's a good video as Ted Cruz
waiting waiting to see if he's on bite
like he was on the list for Trump right
he didn't make it obviously because he's
like oh I don't want that job but I look
at it I'm like you know does Biden come
in and say oh well you know for the the
good like I want to show you guys that I
can I can do well for you you know like
does he put Ted Cruz on the list and
then he just like [ __ ] him right and
he's like oh I'm just [ __ ] that
wasn't really serious
it looks like it looks like brown here
um someone's giving us some information
um confirmed 53 to 44 in 2021 she was a
former DC District
um but uh she's 51 years old so I I
don't have that confirmed but someone's
saying she's about 51 years old which is
about the exact same age as Amy here
yeah yeah and they're they're I mean
let's see what else Joy has to say here
so there are a lot of people who are
disappointed I will say I was one of
them um and then all of this drama
played out with mayor Garland being just
completely sort of humiliated by Mitch
McConnell and just they wouldn't even
meet with it wouldn't talk with him well
now look at Karma he's now attorney
general and that opens the door for
katangi brown uh uh she is the person
most thought of as me being next up for
us go to see tell us about it
um so so this is this has obviously been
a while back and I think I think um
NewsBusters put this
um from March 30th so let's see
yeah so I think look any of those three
would have been great jurists and
katanji would be a great Supreme Court
Justice she is brilliant she's I got a
deep Soul she's a great writer she's
collegial all the things that
Republicans hate
oh she's she she's thoughtful she's a
decent human being like she sees others
empathy prayers for The Human Condition
she's read the Constitution right I just
you know all the things are like [ __ ]
this is ridiculous those are all the
things we don't want she would wear a
mask in court right crazy [ __ ] she
wouldn't be an [ __ ] and respect other
people's [ __ ] wishes uh us for a
simple [ __ ] Mass to keep someone sick
she's not a bomb thrower she's gonna fit
in incredibly well on this new court the
DC circuit our nation's second highest
court I also think there are other
people too in that league and so I don't
think we should write them off like you
know Leondra Kruger who's a Justice on
the California Supreme Court who's about
the best lawyer I've ever worked with
um and you know so there's other people
too
um but you know I think what the
president did here is say here's a great
person for our nation's second highest
court she should go up today and and
then along with this other just Rich
diverse competent slate of nominees I
mean this is just a really incredible
day so she's been in office or she's
been she's been a uh a judge almost a
year in that position right uh I believe
so yeah okay
yeah so in the DC in the DC circuit
right right so she's been a federal
judge in the DC circuit for a little
under a year right yeah
I mean I mean she's smart and she knows
what she's doing and why not like you
know anyone should be given an
opportunity I mean look at the [ __ ]
people we have on the on the [ __ ]
bench right now right well you know the
the three that were bought and paid for
all right we got one guy who likes beer
another guy who you know why he cries in
this he cries right right he cries in
his beer we got another guy who uh let
the company what was the the case with
the driver who died in the snowstorm
right in the truck and then that was
Gorsuch and uh he you know uh sided on
this uh on uh for the company as opposed
to the the victim which is the driver
and you've got you know the um
uh
under his eye you know [ __ ]
Federalist
uh I want well I mean tale it's pretty
easy they're [ __ ] bags right yeah yeah I
mean I mean like you said not one ounce
of empathy you know not not one ounce of
of uh American patriotism inside of any
one of them it's all about it's all
about who they who who bought and paid
for them in the first place
um breaking uh Mueller she wrote says
Justice Breyer to retire hoping POTUS
nominates the first black woman the
scotus uh katanji uh Brown Jackson to
replace him so this is um this is a
movement that's starting to happen I
would imagine that she's going to start
trending here on on Twitter soon so get
your tweets get your tweets written if
you want to be in the trendy Trends and
the Tweety tweets because I think um if
you have something to say about Miss
Brown Jackson you're you're gonna you're
gonna Trend here because she's gonna
looks like she's gonna come out to the
Forefront because like Joey said she was
the second on the list for Barack Obama
when he picked when he picked mayor
Garland so right um very interesting uh
let's go back to the there's something
else I think there was something else I
wanted oh yes oh yes the Kid Rock thing
um I want to get your take on this did
you see Kid Rock I don't know if he's
trending any more hard here because
we've got a lot of [ __ ] going on was it
happy with this song well Willie
Nelson's still trending
um I actually here's what I here's what
I tweeted earlier yeah it has to do with
this song uh we have Willie Nelson on
the side of equality they have Kid Rock
on the side of division enough said
right you know like is that is that is
that enough to tell you where we're at
like honestly they're they're like yeah
Kid Rock with his song of division right
like and and Willie Nelson is down in
Texas
um strawman guitar with Beto O'Rourke
right right like like literally trying
to make sure I did it stands there blue
what's funny is uh I did a video when
this summer when uh Marjorie Taylor
green and Matt Gates were on their tour
which by the way there was a new
development on the Matt gate side I
don't saw that but uh uh yeah there's
someone uh actually played guilty yeah
exactly so you know it's closing on them
but I did a video on their America first
tour and it was like damn that's myself
Jesus Christ
I'm so used to it go ahead uh go ahead
with the kid right yeah so they were on
uh they're on their like America first
tour
and the video premise is there
bartenders you know and they're like
making drinks right and it's all the
different [ __ ] that these people would
drink and you know the special guest at
the end you know is Kid Rock and so you
know it comes out saying dress up as Kid
Rock yeah man oh my God we gotta get Kid
Rock back in the videos then I gotta
yeah you know yeah he was he came maybe
you can work him into the Supreme Court
video the Supreme Court video you know
oh he's gonna be a nominee you think
well I mean you know maybe he thinks
he's supposed to run for Senate or some
[ __ ] isn't he like in Michigan or some
[ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] like he's gonna
run or something like okay so I didn't
even know I didn't even know where he's
like that I totally forgot where Kid
Rock is from right to to know that he
would even run in Michigan like I just
thought he lived in the South somewhere
right right right well you know the
Michigan is the the armpit of the
Midwest I'm just kidding Michigan
there's some good people I know I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding you you do have
Kid Rock though you do have Kid Rock
yeah um Texas has Willie Nelson and Beto
here though that Eugene said since
Willie Nelson is trending trending I'm
thinking this is a good time to post
Will Nelson and better jamming Legends
um let's let's take a listen here
[Music]
thank you
you can see Willie here on the stage
let's do this you know what's great
about this what's great about this is
here here's these these lib tards that
are for equality and justice and all
that good [ __ ] she's such a crazy
radical thing to be right you know right
and here they are Willie Nelson with a
guitar better with a guitar standing in
front of a big ass [ __ ] American flag
yeah [ __ ] how do you like that [ __ ]
take that [ __ ] Flag back Willie ain't
scared to stand in front of the flag he
ain't scared we need to take that [ __ ]
back from these [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I'm gonna get too down into the the
uh the Willy Rabbit Hole so thanks
thanks Eugene for for giving us um the
video there did I give him credit I was
giving myself credit there yeah you just
keep giving yourself Credit Union I'm
just pushing the [ __ ] buttons over
here calm down calm down all right I'm
trying to make sure that I get you know
I get on the [ __ ] list Roundup as if the
whole time you're just making a a a a
threat of your own credits to your wife
I do go down my timeline sometimes you
know that's why I start sometimes but
you know I I I show my own tweets or my
[ __ ] tweets
I know you know you know how many times
your tweets show up on this thing you
know yeah come on big you get into it
Randy Trends a lot a lot a lot you're in
the trendy dreams okay let's um so we'll
go over let's let's stop the Kid Rock
Willie Nelson stuff because we all know
who wins that battle that's not even a
funny contest here and the other thing
the other thing that was trending
earlier was Colin Cameron oh there's
Jordan Peterson thing uh Jordan Peterson
went on uh The Joe Rogan show let me see
if I can again wasn't he on there before
I guess I don't [ __ ] know in the Indy
from Canon or some [ __ ] I don't know
what I don't know what what is this what
is this [ __ ] I'm not let me let me find
the let me [ __ ] let's search it here
because I don't know um
where it's at let's see well let's just
go over here
did it do
Jordan Peterson thread
um oh the first thing that pops up is 50
says remember when Jordan Peterson's
flawed logic was tied in a knot by Jim
Jefferies oh this should be good let's
see what uh let's see what this is about
making people bake a cake for a gay
wedding making them do it yeah I don't
think that's a very good idea but here's
the argument so should they be able to
deny making a cake for a black couple if
they don't like black people
allowed to probably that doesn't mean
it's right okay so then we have the
Civil Rights Movement where they said
black people we underserve them in your
restaurants and stuff like that and it
did work and it did make our society
better but would you argue that that
still wasn't right
no that was right
why why now if you didn't want to make a
cake for like like people
maybe it's not maybe it's not different
maybe I was wrong about that
so this is this is Jordan Peterson uh I
I think you have to jump off here is
that right yeah yeah all right but I
will say Jim Jefferies is you know
always spot on whether it's about you
know gun laws in Australia or dynamop
into logic here
uh you know why yeah well I mean he does
a fantastic job of breaking it down to
the simple right right because they
always want to make these issues
complicated that way they can use the
complication to their advantage
um for the really ridiculous argument
that they have
um so all right well I'm gonna watch
more of this and uh we'll catch you
later Gabe everybody say bye to Gabe
thank you for joining us Gabe we'll
we'll see you well maybe we'll see you
tomorrow right I think they will we have
an interview is that interview Gonna Be
Ready you think maybe yeah I believe so
okay good good good all right maybe I'll
announce that all right thanks Gabe
we'll talk to you soon
all right so let's let's go down um
Hassan here says Jordan Peterson went on
Rogan looking like an oil Baron
to do 30 minutes of some of the most
insane oil lobbyists propaganda I've
ever seen so apparently
um he goes on uh to talk about climate
change it sounds like and to climate
change deny I guess uh what do we got
here
let's see
um MJ says now I love Gabe Moore that
gun control bit is amazeballs yeah and
Jim Jefferies the the gun I think that's
what you're talking about MJ is
fantastic but here here's a clip bad
stats has a clip here from the show
um a weird one so
let's see if we can see what the hell
these morons are talking about hard to
sort out the climate change one is a
weird one so that well that's because
there's no such thing as climate right
climate and everything are the same word
oh for [ __ ] sake I I can't even do it
I can't even do it it's not even gonna
be worth it this these this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
not not see that this is what the [ __ ]
they do right this is how they do it
this is how they do it this is what me
and Rachel were talking about in the
front the front part of the show in the
first hour in the first half hour my
first half 40 minutes
is that these [ __ ] they they go
down so far down the [ __ ] rabbit hole
and here he is here he is saying
here he is saying that climate doesn't
even exist like not only not only is he
challenging that climate change like he
doesn't have a good [ __ ] argument for
that probably so the best thing he can
do is just dispute that even climate
exists as long as climate doesn't exist
you can't have the changing of it right
that's how [ __ ] crazy these people
get wrapped up
and these hair brain [ __ ] ideas
um bad stat says holy moly I don't think
I could do this first words out of
Peterson's mouth that Joe Rogan
interview your complete self-parity
can't even dunk on it
oh my God I didn't read that but until
now but I feel the same exact way like
oh my God you [ __ ] boneheads climate
doesn't exist it's not a word and it's
not a thing it just isn't because I
don't want it to be because if it is
then I have to confront it and that
would be horrible if we have to actually
confront ideas or 34 minutes into the
second hour have you guys liked the show
so far today it's been it's there's been
a lot Happening Here on the Tony
Michaels bad guest we had Rachel
bickoffer
in the first hour we doing the [ __ ] list
Roundup here in the second hour we had
Gabe come on this is this is uh this is
shaping up to be a good day okay let's
see what else do we have in the training
Trends and tweet tweets I had some other
things I wanted to touch on well let's
see what they were
um before we moved too far forward I
want to make sure we don't hit miss any
subjects
um with Colin K oh Nina Turner that's
the other one and manka Rappaport was
also was also trending earlier now let's
see if he's still on yeah he's still on
the list number 11 here Michael Rapaport
um apparently
um Michael was in uh here here's the
Tweet now he was in he was in like a
Rite Aid or CVS or Walgreens or some
[ __ ] and this guy's walking out and um
he just says what did I just witness
dude went straight shopping
um obviously he's accusing him
of a stealing stuff
and um here's the video
everyone's really [ __ ] upset with
this
every like everyone's upset
of course you see you see um he's
pointing out this guy here that's
walking out with the stuff that
Michael's supposedly saying you walked
out with but you see right right there
right what does that say that's a
security guard right so
um it goes around
yo
yo
I just watched this [ __ ] dude
look at this [ __ ] guy
walk in the [ __ ] Rite Aid take a
whole this [ __ ] guy right here take a
whole bunch of [ __ ]
look at him
so so everyone's really upset at Michael
Rapaport for this video like they're
they're pissed off
um the right the left and I don't know
but I mean like I don't know I mean
maybe if the guy was shoplifting the
security guard would have done something
about it yeah I don't know I don't know
like our airport likes to take a lot of
[ __ ] videos with a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] of course it's got like a half
million views here you know I I know I
don't know that's why this is why he's
trending and then the right's like oh
you vote you vote for Democrats this is
what happens what
what you vote for Democrats and someone
shopless what the [ __ ] are you talking
about as if no one was shoplifting when
when people vote for Republicans get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
get out of here with that [ __ ] there's
always people gonna have economic Strife
in this country and people with economic
stripe a lot of times shoplift sometimes
they're just straight criminals but
sometimes to eat they got a shoplift I
mean there are those situations
so you know
I get I guess I guess thanks Michael
Rapaport for your tweet I don't know oh
I already I already thanked him for it
um but that that's the tweet and and the
takes are uh you know
few far between it's it's really it's
it's I know I don't know I don't know I
didn't understand why why it was so
important that he trend for that video
like there's so many more videos that
Michael could [ __ ] uh trend for
[ __ ] Twitter there wasn't there
wasn't a lot of news this morning before
Justice Breyer retired there just wasn't
there just wasn't
um okay um what was the other thing we
wanted to talk about here
oh Nina Turner is she still trending or
did she fall off the list
um of course all all the Supreme Court
Justice stuff is trending now it's in a
Judiciary Committee which that's where
the Supreme Court Justice uh will
receive their their their hearing to
move to the floor for a vote
um you've got um
yeah oh the Gat story that's right MJ
thank you
um MJ says gets I call him gets not
Gates it's gets it's Matt gets and the
reason why is because it's not [ __ ]
spelled Gates it's not spell Gates so I
don't say it like that [ __ ] them and the
way I see it is I'm hoping that
[ __ ] you know if he hears any of
this [ __ ] and he hears me saying his
name wrong intentionally and he hates it
that's why that's why I do it [ __ ] them
yeah I want to say his name wrong
intentionally let's see here
um what was what was the name of the
person it's like Ellicott isn't it
Ellicott or Ellicott or some [ __ ] like
that then the the the guy that pled
guilty
um to
um let's see let's just search it I
think it's Ellicott e l l i c o t t I
think is how it was spelled
um yeah Joe Ellicott let's search it
that way that's what we needed Joe
Ellicott
Fred
uh Mueller she wrote has it here
breaking Joe Ellicott who just pled
guilty and the Matt gets sex trafficking
Scandal was also charged with dealing
Adderall using venmo
oh [ __ ] venmo keeps popping up in
this goddamn story doesn't it
Matt gatz and venmo venmo gets
a quick lookie at his venmo contacts
I'll be talking uh to Robert
um Jay Denault on on the next daily bean
pod
um so
Joe's friends so this looks like a a
screenshot from
um
Joe Ella I think it's Ellicott it's an
Helicon am I saying that [ __ ] right am I
saying that [ __ ] right Joe Ellicott
um it looks like he met gatz is a buddy
of his on venmo I wonder I wonder if he
was dealing Adderall on venmo
what uh what kind of purchases
what kind of trading of money there was
I wonder I wonder what I wonder what
let's see what else do we got here
um and and he's a he's a radio show host
did you guys know this here's a picture
of this guy
uh breaking radio host Joe Ellicott has
pled guilty to fraud and drug charges in
federal court
Ellicott is thought to have Insider
information about sex trafficking and
Scandal involvement Matt Getz now the
story that I read okay because you got
to remember Joe Greenberg was also a
radio host did you guys know that Joe
Greenberg was a radio host he he was
like a shock jock kind of thing and then
and then he wasn't you know he kind of
kind of floundered at that so he went
and ran for the the public tax
commissioner or whatever the tax
collector whatever the [ __ ] he was
um
so
so uh I think that's how he knows this
Joe Ellicott character
um and how they were venmoing each other
for Adderall
um but this Joe Ellicott has not been
charged
with indictment by a by a grand jury
okay so the grand jury didn't issue an
indictment to Joe Ellicott right just
like the grand jury is not issue an
indictment to
um uh Matt gatz's ex-girlfriend who is
supposed to
receive immunity for her role
in in testifying before the grand jury
right so there is a grand jury convened
in this Joel Greenberg sick trafficking
case and they're continuing the ongoing
investigation now Joe Ellicott was not
indicted out of that out of that grand
jury that's significant that means that
Joe Ellicott knew he had a legalized
criminal liability here and between him
and his attorneys they were able to
proffer and probably work out a deal
with the federal prosecutors to plead
guilty in exchange for information and
to testify in front of the grand jury
not not be the subject of it but to go
testify in front of it with evidence
receipts
this is very bad I would say
um not only to shore up the cases that
are made in The Plea deals against not
only uh Joe Greenberg but uh just Joe
Ellicott but also also which would speak
to the immunity of Matt gatz's
ex-girlfriend why they wanted immunity
in the obstruction of justice charge so
because Joe Ellicott has not been
indicted by this by a grand jury I think
that's significant I think it's
significant maybe it's not but I think
it is
um in the story here because the
girlfriend also hasn't been so uh here
is uh
Greg Fox posted this who's Greg fox
looks like a news reporter uh with uh
WESH 2 news that might be in I guess
that's in Florida maybe uh breaking news
update below is the photo provided the
source close to the case of Joseph Big
Joe is what they call him Ellicott
um he was a groomsman at the former
Seminole County Tax Collector Joe
Greenberg's wedding
Ellicott has agreed to cooperate fully
in the Justice so not only is this guy
radios with with Joel Greenberg the guy
was in his [ __ ] wedding
I guess you don't get much closer when
your venmo and Matt gets to sell some
Adderall and during during Joe
Greenberg's wedding I don't know I'm
just snowballing here
I don't know what actually happened [ __ ]
I don't know we're gonna find out though
don't you think don't you think we're
gonna find out I know Matt Gantz is
gonna find out he [ __ ] around
he's gonna [ __ ] find out
um so that's that's uh let's see if we
can find
yeah Greenberg was a seminal uh MJ says
the Seminole County Tax Collector but
before he got elected a tax collector
that guy was a was a radio host just
like this Joe Ellicott I think that is
that how you say the name Joe Ellicott I
don't know [ __ ] maybe I should say it
the way I want to say it just like I say
Matt Gantz uh let's see
see if there's any other really good
news here
um other than he pled guilty in court
and it seems like this is very very very
[ __ ] bad for Magda it's like a
horrible situation because the other
thing the other thing significant about
him not being charged
are indicted by a grand jury and
pleading to charges outside of being
indicted by the grand jury when he goes
in front of a federal magistrate a
federal judge when you receive
sentencing and they do his guidelines as
federal guidelines to be sentenced
um he he's he's likely to receive points
for that this guy's probably looking to
do uh probation he's looking not to go
to a federal prison and that's why he
didn't wait around for a [ __ ] Federal
grand jury to indict his ass his
attorneys are like nope you need to go
in you need to sing so it seems like
this last year where we've been
wondering why hasn't Matt Getz been
charged with a crime it seems like the
federal prosecutors are building their
case and they're building their case
through immunity deals and plea deals so
um I don't know how soon it will come
but I would say Matt Getz reaches the
the the find out phase of the [ __ ]
around Saga the go Joe Greenberg [ __ ]
around Saga soon enough okay uh let's
see what else do we have we are 45
minutes in the hour we got about 15
minutes left
um also Nina Turner that's the other
story I wanted to get to do let's see if
she's still trending um you guys know
that uh Nina Turner Nina Turner
uh announced her run again
in Michigan
um let me just
now just search her up here
um
I want the
the full story there's her tweets
do
of course
um she's gonna be running against
Chantal Brown Chris Chris says here
Bernie Sanders surrogate and Nina Turner
has announced she's running for congress
again
mounting a primary chance to incumbent
Chantel Brown in Ohio 11. uh will you be
supporting her
um so rather you are or not I mean this
is this is Nina Turner's right to run a
primary against uh Chantal brown but at
the same time this is this is really a
waste of a lot of people's money okay
um this is the [ __ ] that Democrats do
that Republicans don't do
um they don't do it they don't do it
they're not gonna run someone who's
going to raise a [ __ ] ton of money to
try to and lose Chantal Brown is likely
to keep her seat in Ohio's 11. right I'm
I I you know regardless of what you
believe about Nina Turner or or Chantel
Brown regardless of what you believe
about him Chantel Brown is likely to
keep that seat
uh that she's likely to win that primary
race that the only thing that's going to
happen
is it Nina Turner has takes donations
from a lot of what you would assume
would be Bernie Sanders supporters but
that's not exactly true
right
so the the point is is that if Nina
Turner gets in this race and raises a
bunch of money now Chantal Brown and the
D Triple C have to raise money and maybe
mount a campaign against Nina Turner
here
now all the money that could be used for
for Nina Turner to fight out Chantal
Brown and Ohio's 11th could be used in
other races a lot of other races like
the Ohio senate race
or Tim Ryan is going to run
um it could possibly be used there
and that Federal race for Senate where
we could pick up an actual seat in the
Senate where um you know if Nina Turner
really wanted Democrats to have the
majority in the Senate she wanted to
have Democrats in in Ohio representing
Ohio you know she would definitely
definitely throw her hat in the ring and
make sure that not only that they won
the 11th but they won the state as well
now she may believe that she's the one
and she has that right she has a right
to run no one can stop her from running
in this primary all's I'm saying out
there that if you're going to throw your
support behind Nina Turner realize
realize the ramifications of what your
support means now you may be you may be
diametrically opposed to Brown and fully
full throat Elite support Turner
but there's other races in Ohio that are
at stake here as well
and the turnout is going to be important
now maybe Nina Turner's uh a little uh
her primary years to try to get turnout
but the turnout that we need is not just
in the primaries it's in the general
election that's where we're going to
bury these fascists underneath boats so
really really think hard really think
hard about some of these races where
Democrats are coming in and trying to
raise National money to get rid of
incumbent Democrats
right and states where we want to win
the United States Senate seat as well
and I'm not saying that because Nina
Turner would win the primary the Tim Tim
Ryan would lose what I'm saying is all
the money that is going to be spent for
Nina Turner and Chantel Brown to find
out the Ohio is a limit in a primary
could well be spent to make sure that
whoever the nominee is wins Ohio's 11th
and we can also put a United States
senator in the senate in Ohio
which is one one more [ __ ] you to
Cinnamon Mansion you want to tell Cinema
and Mansion to go [ __ ] themselves get
Tim Ryan to win in Ohio that's what the
[ __ ] you do
you you want you want to give the big
middle [ __ ] finger in the Senate to
mansion and Cinema put a [ __ ]
Democrat in the senate in Ohio
that's willing that's willing to go as
far to vote with Democrats on [ __ ] like
voting rights
yeah
I'm sure Tim Ryan would vote for voting
rights for crying out loud
he would also probably vote for Bill
back better the Big Bird bill as I call
it here
because Tim Ryan pushes for American
Working Families in Ohio
so if you want if you think you want a
Democrat like Tim Ryan to win
and you want a Democrat to be in Ohio's
11th you should really think about what
is the ramifications of making sure that
money goes into the Ohio the 11th race
and how much money you're willing to
spend in the primary just in the primary
of the Ohio 11. before you pick who
you're supporting
this is what Democrats always fail to
[ __ ] recognize
and you can call me oh you're moderate
and you're you're against Bernie I'm not
against Bernie or Nina Turner at all
need to turn it down done did loss to
Chantelle Brown done lost
don't spent the money done lost so we're
gonna spend the money again as a party
you're gonna give your money
to it to a race that's gonna have a
democrat in the first place when you
could give you could give your money to
the general election in Ohio's 11th or
give your money to the senate race in
Ohio to make sure Ohio is a Democratic
Senate seat
come on we got to get real we got to get
with this [ __ ] we got to put our [ __ ]
boxing gloves on and we got to stop
[ __ ] putting hot coals all over each
other [ __ ] this [ __ ]
so when you're considering because
you're you're welcome to support either
one either right you can support Nina
Turner if you want no one's going to
stop you No One's Gonna Stop you no one
can stop you
but just understand the ramifications
when you back a candidate that you may
you may really like and the other
candidate you may not like just
understand the ramifications when when
[ __ ] doesn't go your way in your state
or in that state or in those State races
because the money was spent for them
Democrats to fight it out and to box
each other in the face not not too smart
to not really consider this before you
throw your support that's all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying
so good luck to Nina Turner there in her
announcement and I wish her the best of
luck and I hope that she understands
um what she's uh doing and that I hope
that she's trying to pull Democrats all
over the line
um but knowing Nina Turner I I I'm not
so sure of it
um I'm not so sure so uh uh let's go
back and see what else we have oh the No
Labels was trending
let's see oh Chris Chris I'm so glad
you're keeping us keeping us in check
here oh my gosh I'm so glad you stay in
hate watch isn't everyone glad in the
chat that Chris stays and hate watches
the whole time I'm so happy that Chris
is here I really am make sure you
comment a couple times on this video
Chris that way you can push the
algorithm that way more people can see
it on the ass end of the show you know
on YouTube because we got viewers on
Twitch and Twitter and we get thousands
of views every single day over on
Twitter I mean if you uh if you go look
at the video feed you know that all
right let's uh let's see what else do we
got trending and the trendy Trends and
the Tweety tweets I like Chris
yeah and MJ says we love Chris thank you
Chris thank you for all the work that
you do inside the chat and in the
comments and boosting the algorithm we
really do appreciate you being here
actually you know what you should do
Chris is go invite some more of your
hate watching friends we'd really like
to have them here we'd really like to
have them in the comments it would be a
lot of fun it would be a lot of fun okay
let's see what else do we get
of course uh Kagan is trending uh black
woman is trending
um because everyone is
um chomping at the bit with this Supreme
Court retirement announcement of breyer
um I don't know how fast the president
will actually announce this it'll
probably come sometime next week I would
imagine the administration is going to
give time uh someone said the president
spoke I don't know maybe we can go find
that let's see if um let's see if C-SPAN
has that
the president speaking on this issue
oh this is a Joe Biden speaking in 1994
and a Senate Judiciary Committee hearing
where he was the chair he says today the
Senate Judiciary Committee welcomes
judge Stephen Breyer the president's
nominee to be associate Justice of the
Supreme Court of the United States so
they have history here let's let's watch
a bit of this
judge and Mrs Pryor welcome
we're delighted to have you here
the first issue when we get to questions
we'll be resolving what state you're
really from
but I uh you are indeed privileged this
morning to have
four of our distinguished colleagues
anxious to be associated with your
nomination and uh one in particular uh
um maybe is a considerably responsible
for your nomination
so there's Joe Biden giving his thoughts
all the way back in 1994 when Justice
Breyer was actually nominated so seeing
that these do have history I would
imagine
um that there's going to be some sort of
period here where Joe Biden takes time
to make his pick and I'm sure they have
a short list of who they want and who
they wanted if Breyer was going to
retire this looks like from C-SPAN 21
minutes ago
um and it looks like President Biden
every justice has the right and
opportunity to decide announce it on
their own there's been no announcement
from Justice Breyer let him make
whatever statement he's going to make
I'll be happy to talk about it later
let's listen to the president here
yeah
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
was this today I'm not sure it looks
like it was close to the couple 20
minutes ago
has the right opportunity to decide what
he or she is going to do to denounce it
on their own
there has been no announcement from
Justice Breyer let him make whatever
statement he's going to make and I'll be
happy to talk about it later thank you
okay so so they are it does look like
they're going to uh discuss this later
um so um again more more news from the
from the Supreme Court pick uh we are 56
minutes into the second hour
um
uh let's see what else do we have here
um some people are saying he said they
will be gathering very soon okay uh oh
hey Andrea how are you hi uh trying to
come in more yeah that's cool come come
join us every single weekday noon
Eastern 11th century right here on
YouTube Twitter twitch
so we got the new time so we're not
we're not actually going to have the
podcast this afternoon because we had it
this morning right now you guys
witnessed it just here you were just
with the podcast and we did the [ __ ]
list Roundup
you know and and we're going to do that
every single weekday Newton Eastern 11
Central today we had Rachel bitkoffer
for for those who were a little like
coming in so you're going to want to go
re-watch the first part of the podcast
with Rachel bitkoffer
um she came in she gave us some insight
I'm gonna try to have her on like every
single week that's what I'm gonna try to
do do you guys want to hear from Rachel
every single week um she gets me fired
up when she's talking about uh election
and messaging and and their strategic
outrage that we need to have to stay
pissed and go [ __ ] vote because
Democrats are the only ones that are
going to deliver any of these policies
that anyone wants out in this country
because Republicans are hell-bent on
destroying everything destroying our
democracy I mean they want to destroy
our democracy
and we're we're we're we're arguing with
each other what what the actual minimum
wage number is going to be
right
uh MJ says yes more Rachel
uh okay well we're going to bring Rachel
in more and more if we can if she'll if
she'll come on the show uh we're super
excited to have her in but don't forget
don't forget to go over to the YouTube
channel and if you're here already go
ahead and click the Subscribe button
like share all that kind of [ __ ]
whatever whatever you're supposed to do
you know click the thing and you know
IMA whatever whatever the hell I'm
supposed to say to get you to do it now
Yoda says weekly Rachel [ __ ] yeah hell
yeah I think we will try to get Rachel
in every week I'm gonna try to get
Michael popock in tomorrow maybe we'll
get his um his his stance on this
Supreme Court Justice thing and uh what
he thinks of some of the nominees or
that are being or some of the names that
are being brought up as nominees uh what
he thinks of them because I know he
probably knows some of these uh District
judges
um especially the the the
um
um some of these judges that are on the
list I'm forgetting the names but
there's a couple uh DC justices that are
on the list so you really I really want
you to interview politics girl I would I
would welcome Lee on the show I I've
talked to Lee she's a very busy busy
lady when she's doing her videos and her
podcast now
um you love Pop yeah we all love Pop
here so hopefully we can get Pope on
tomorrow to give give his uh his opinion
of the Supreme Court pick here
um and the the opening that is for a
nether liberal Justice again it's we're
just going to replace a liberal Justice
with the liberal Justice the vote's not
going to change uh the significance of
this is is really the age of the justice
as opposed to being older they can be
younger like Amy about the same age as
Amy Connie Barrett possibly some of
these nominees seem to have that age so
don't forget
um this afternoon we don't have a
podcast this afternoon it's right here
every weekday noon Eastern 11 Central
now we change the time we change the
time so go go tomorrow make sure you're
here on YouTube on Twitter on Twitch to
watch the Tony Michaels podcast and help
us with the shitless Roundup
and really until tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon